MARK MIRCHANDANI: A
surprise party might be fun,
but a surprise on your
Cloud bill usually isn't.
Thankfully, you can set
up budgets and alerts
using Google Cloud Platform
to closely monitor your costs
and work with the
appropriate teams
so that they can take
action if needed.
On this episode of
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll talk about setting up
budgets and how you can get
notified when anything
unexpected happens.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Setting a budget in GCP lets
you trigger notifications
when your costs hit
or are forecasted
to hit a specified amount.
You can set up a budget for
an entire billing account
or multiple budgets for
different combinations
of projects and GCP
products so that you
can stay informed on the
areas that matter most to you.
Let's look at the
interface where
you can manage your
budgets, set one
up, and see what the options
for notifications are.
We'll start by going to
the Budgets and Alerts
page in the GCP console.
You can use the
top left navigation
to choose Billing, and then
select the billing account.
From there, click on
Budgets and Alerts.
Only billing account
administrators
are able to create or
update budgets and alerts
for a billing account.
So make sure that you
have the right permissions
for the billing account
that you've chosen.
On this page, you can
see all the budgets that
belong to this billing account.
Each budget is made up of a
few different important pieces.
First, you have the name
for the budget, which
is helpful for you
to identify what
this budget is meant to track.
Next is the budget type, which
can either be specified amount,
where you set a fixed amount to
compare your monthly spend to,
or last month's spend, where
you target an amount based
on the previous month's spend.
We'll come back
to those when you
walk through creating a budget.
After that is the
scope of the budget,
which is the combinations
of projects and GCP products
that this budget covers.
So you may have a budget for
your entire billing account,
one for just your
production projects,
BigQuery spend,
or multiple for any
combination of those.
On the other side
of the budget are
the actual threshold details for
when the budget should send out
an alert notification.
Each budget can have
multiple thresholds.
And you can see an overview
of the current status
for each budget on this page.
The thresholds are percentages
of either the amount
you entered or the last
month's spend based
on the type of budget.
You can always come to this
page to see your budgets
and click on one to edit it.
Let's go through and create a
budget to see all the options.
We'll do that by clicking
on the Create Budget button
at the top.
The first screen is the
scope of the budget,
which includes the name,
projects, and products covered.
If you don't choose any projects
or products from the dropdown,
this budget will default to
the entire billing account.
Since you can set up as
many budgets as you want,
feel free to create
multiple budgets
to track different groups
of projects and products
based on your needs.
On the next screen, you can
choose the type of budget.
If you choose
specified amount, you
can choose a target amount for
this budget to track towards.
Depending on the
cost you're trying
to measure, that could be
$100, $100,000, or more.
If you choose last
month's spend,
the amount will be pre-populated
with the spend from last month
based on the scope you
just chose and it'll
be updated every month.
For example, if you
choose a product
that you haven't used
before or you've only
used within the free tier, this
amount may show up as zero.
This can be a good
way to get notified
as soon as you start to
spend money on something
you didn't expect
to spend it on.
In addition, you can
choose to include credits
in the budget amount.
Including credits means
you'll take the total cost
and then subtract any
credits that were applied
for that billing period.
Credits may include things like
usage discounts, promotions,
or grants.
On the next step, you'll be
able to set up the actions.
You can set up
different thresholds
based on the amount from
the previous step for when
the alert notification
should trigger.
For example, you may want
to set an alert for when
you've reached 50%, 90%,
and 100% of your budget
for the month.
You can also add additional
thresholds in case
you want more granularity.
And each threshold can be based
on actual or forecasted costs.
Actual cost thresholds
trigger when
the spend from the
scope that you selected
exceeds the specified amount.
For example, you could set up
a 50% actual cost threshold
on $1,000 budget, and you'll
get an alert notification
when your cost exceeds $500.
Forecasted cost
thresholds trigger
when your cost is predicted
to exceed the threshold
amount by the end of the month.
If you add a forecasted
cost threshold
for 110% on a $1,000
budget, it will
trigger an alert
notification as soon
as your cost for the
total billing period
is expected to hit
$1,100 even if you're
only a few days into the month.
There is also an option for
connecting budget to pub/sub
for programmatic budget
notifications, which
let you add more advanced
cost controls to your budgets.
We'll talk about that
in a later video.
But you can check out the link
below for more information.
Keep in mind that different
GCP products or services update
costs at different times.
Most services will update
costs within an hour.
But some may take up to
a full day to update.
Each service has costs based
on different metrics as well.
We recommend setting
multiple budgets
so that you can get
alerted as soon as possible
and take action.
Once you save your
budget, you're good to go.
Though, it may take a few
hours before it kicks in.
Here's an email alert
that was sent out
for a budget that was set
to 100% for a $10 budget.
We can see the display name of
the budget, the budget amount
and period, the triggering
threshold, and the associated
billing account ID in the email.
It's also easy to get straight
to the Budget page in case
you want to see more information
or edit your budgets.
Only billing account
administrators
and billing account users
will get an email notification
for a budget alert.
Remember, budget alerts are sent
out based on the rules you set,
but they don't actually stop
any usage from happening.
If you want to go beyond
emails and automate actions,
you should consider using
quotas or programmatic budget
notifications.
Both of which we'll talk
about in future videos.
Check out the links below for
more information about setting
up budgets and alerts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]